the math singer moved to thursday this
week for a special thanksgiving day
episode and surprisingly it had a
canadian connection when
broccoli had their time cut short on the
show
yes narrowly missing out on the super
six
let's take a look at broccoli's last
broken performance
and the judge who discussed right when
they were revealed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
legendary entertainer
[Applause]
[Music]
i love it uh would you have guessed that
was him
under there no no no i know
it's so weird watching the show like
yeah it's so weird watching this show
like i tried it like i closed my eyes a
lot when i'm listening
um because like on the show like jojo
you know i feel like one of them is jojo
last season i already knew it was bow
wow um oh you did close your eyes you
can kind of pick it up a little bit
better
um well my gosh what a fun show
i'd love to see canadian
i know i love it so i looked up his age
he's 79
and he's just sporting that costume he
actually said he didn't think he was
going to last this long
um so he had to get used to the costume
much more than he realized he was going
to have to
um he said that first performance is
really hard like the costume is really
heavy
um this isn't how he normally goes out
on stage so just the fact that
he you know owned this and his age had
so much fun and the whole
inspiration for him to do this show he
said he just wanted to get out of his
house during covet he's working on a new
album
he felt pretty isolated he said so he
just wanted to get out there and like
kudos because i think he
rocked it yeah no totally and you know
what these productions like when you're
doing when you're in covet and you're
quarantined at home and whatnot
um yes productions are pretty awesome
just in terms of their procedures and
how many kova tests you do and the way
that they teach you about cobit and how
to isolate
there's just so much information and
actually working when they're filming
through right now that
yeah if you're at home doing nothing
doing the math singer sounds like a lot
of fun and those yeah those costumes are
very hot
now diane is saying uh blown away paul
anka
um addie is saying uh uh who would have
guessed paul
paul would show up on something like the
math singer at all
which is true and i think that's why
even if robin thicke did understand who
it was like
it's still like a pretty huge um
surprise for so many people and liz is
saying
way to go he did well for 79. i want to
know would you
be on this show is this something you've
ever thought about doing you obviously
have the voice
thank you um yeah i would totally love
to do a show like massinger that'd be so
much fun especially
um there's some singers that can change
their voice
um and i can change my voice into
probably three or four sounds where you
wouldn't know
is me so i would love to do that that
would be really fun
have you practiced that how do you know
you can do that you just know
um just it's just like doing karaoke as
like a child
and doing it constantly to train my and
then you know sounding different on each
song and then it just evolved into
different voices